cet après midi se déroulait à l'elysée
le traditionnel arbre de noël en
présence de françois mitterrand quatre
des classes invitées à cette fête venez
d'île de france
parmi elles une classe d'enfants
handicapés du xiiie arrondissement et à
coût moyen première année des murs haute
dans une une école situé dans un îlot
sensible où se trouve surtout des livres
des enfants d'immigrés des enfants qui
pour la plupart ne sont jamais sortis
des mureaux marie-pierre subtil les a
donc suivi depuis hier pour recueillir
leurs impressions avant et pendant la
réception à l'elysée
lorsque les 21 élèves de la classe ont
appris qu'ils étaient invités à l'elysée
ils ont pensé que c'était une blague
ils y ont cru que le jour où ils ont
reçu une invitation personnelle - portal
je dors tu le lis le président de la
république et madame françois mitterrand
pris par la lorraine tout le de l'enfer
meneur d'assister à la route noël le
mercredi 14 ans en 1983 à 14h45 ont pas
la donnée d'ici une invitation à
laquelle on répondra dans les formes à
monsieur le président de la république
monsieur le président nous sommes très
heureux d'avoir été choisi pour
participer à l'arbre de noël du palais
de l'elysee vous remercier de votre
généreuse invitation nous vous remettons
ses dessins d'objets typiques de nos
différents pays
nous serions très contents si vous les
acceptez car nous vous les offrons du
fond du coeur a causé leur marque
ah bon autre chose nous arrive ce sera
saint siège c'est comme dans tout le
pays d'accueil donc quelque chose à lui
dire oui quoi pourquoi qu'il est devenu
président avant tu te demandes pourquoi
il a voulu bruit définir le rôle du
président est un problème
imaginez l'elysée en est un autre aussi
épineux c'est comment l'elysée
comment tu imagines je crois que c'est
grand et puis c'est un illuminé
c'est une grande salle et il ya beaucoup
de chaises ce sera quoi les séquences
sont a été signé
si l'on se réjouissait talibés du
spectacle et des jouets du moins pour la
plupart crb à lui n'a que faire déjouer
il a bien d'autres soucis est à la fois
pourquoi tu vas les visées de moments là
pour vous conseiller d'aller poser une
question à laquelle question pourquoi il
fait la guerre pour passer tour à guerre
avec d'autres pays et un jour n'arrivera
à calais avec la trappe partout il y
aura plein de noirs et j'ai pas envie de
mourir
le grand jour est arrivé cet après midi
cerbère peut poser sa question
pas de réponse mais néanmoins un très
bon souvenir de la journée
des martiens
dimanche
et à
avec qui il était
10 e on
nous a montré
c'est trop tendue
tout au début
des clowns
voulez vous
oui
il ya un prix de marché